أعلن البنتاغون بالأمس أنه
كان خطأ غارة الطائرات بدون طيار على
المطار التي أودت بحياة 10 أشخاص و 10
مدنيين.  ليست المرة الأولى التي يرتكبون فيها
أخطاء ،
فربما تكون هذه هي المرة الأخيرة
التي استهدفوا فيها المدنيين مرارًا وتكرارًا في
إطار عملياتهم في غارات جوية في
أفغانستان.
السنوات
التي استهدفوا فيها الآلاف من النساء
والأطفال المدنيين الأبرياء واستشهدوا ، لقد استنكرنا
بالفعل الضربة الجوية الأخيرة ، وهذا دليل قاطع
على مقتل المدنيين وتضررهم ،
وقد تم دعوة الفتيان في الصف السادس
إلى الصف الثاني عشر ولكن
لم نكن فتيات.  أخبرنا أنه سيكون
هناك تعليم للفتيات حتى التعليم العالي ،
لذا فإن ما يحدث
جيدًا نحن في طور وضع
gr  نظرًا لأن الفتيات من الصف السادس حتى الصف الثاني
عشر يحتاجن إلى وسائل نقل آمنة ،
وهناك أيضًا قواعد معينة
لفصلهن ودروس يجب مراعاتها
حتى يكونوا آمنين ، فنحن
نعمل على ذلك وستكتمل العملية وسيسمح
لنا بذلك.  هل لديك فتيات في الجامعات
يواصلن تعليمهن في كل
من الجامعات الممولة من الحكومة والخاصة ،
ولكن بدءًا من الصف السادس إلى الثاني عشر ،
نحن في طور إرساء
الأساس
الذي يجري العمل عليه
في عملية في هذا الصدد
[الموسيقى]
أنت